(audience cheering)
Welcome back,
before we say good bye,
we play a quick round of Drewth or Dare.
(suspenseful music playing)
(audience cheering)
That's right, you get to ask me anything
or tell me to do anything.
And today we have Gia Zampella.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much for being here, Gia.
Thank you, I flew in from LA last night.
I think you're familiar.
I am, are you kidding with this valley girl accent, yes?
Gia Drewth or Dare?
Drewth.
Okay. (sighs)
Who is the last person you were stalking,
creeping on social, and did you find anything good?
(audience laughs)
Come on, Drew. (laughs)
Okay, I'm on a dating app
and all the men are really creepy and coy.
They won't tell you who they are or what they do.
And all their Instagram accounts are private.
So yes, sometimes I Google their name. (Gia laughs)
(audience laughs)
I do a little like, and then I'm like,
"Oh, finally I found the name."
And I just am trying to figure out who they are.
And usually I resent them by the time
I figured out who they are,
(audience laugh)
that they made it this hard.
(Gia laughs)
But yeah, I totally Google guys
on my dating app because I can't figure out
who they are on the dating app.
(audience laughs)
Nice.
And recently one guy I found out owned a bakery.
Another one was a meditator.
Another one was a finance guy.
And I will tell you this and don't feel sorry for me
cause it's just what happens to all of us women out there.
No one has connected with me.
(audience laughs)
It makes me feel like such a loser.
And then you're like, you know what?
It's just hard out there, it's hard for everybody.
It's hard in person, it's hard on dating apps.
It's vulnerable, but you keep trying
and you fill your life up with so much
that it becomes secondary.
I don't think my happiness is on this dating app.
I think a cherry on top to my life at some convenient,
cool, inspiring, unexpected time
might be in there, but it's,
that's all it is.
So does that answer your question Gia?
I think it does, I'm manifesting somebody for you, so
it's gonna happen.
(audience claps)
When you want it, when you want it.
I am desperate in plenty of areas in my life
and dating isn't one of them.
I love that.
Isn't that so refreshing?
Yeah, refreshing.
(audience clapping)
Thank you for this day, this is so fun.
All right, that's all the time we have.
Thank you so much, for choosing to spend your time with us,
Thank you Gia.
We make the show for you, so take it with you.
(upbeat music playing)